Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour à tous !
J’aimerais qu’on commence
par un petit jeu, tous ensemble,
qui consiste à lire
une phrase à voix haute.
Est-ce que vous êtes prêts ?
On y va à trois.
Un, deux, trois.
Les chaussettes de l’archiduchesse
sont-elles sèches, archisèches ?
Ce n’est pas facile, on est d’accord.
Avez-vous eu cette sensation de faire
un maximum d’efforts
pour articuler correctement,
mais de quand même vous planter ?
Ouais, mais vous venez de vivre
une partie du quotidien d’une personne
avec des troubles dys.
Peut-être une partie du quotidien
d’un de vos voisins, d’un de vos amis,
d’un de vos enfants
et peut-être même votre quotidien.
Mais en tout cas, c'est mon quotidien.
Aujourd’hui, je ne vais pas seulement
vous parler de dyslexiques,
mais bien de troubles dys,
parce que cette dernière vient souvent
accompagnée de quelques copines.
Pour ma part :
dyscalculie, dysorthographie.
Bien souvent, quand je parle
de ma dyslexie, on me dit :
« Pffff mais c’est juste
que t’es nulle en orthographe.
Puis de toute façon, maintenant,
tout le monde est dyslexique. »
Parce qu’il y a
de plus en plus de personnes
qui sont nulles en orthographe.
Alors oui, c’est vrai, je suis nulle
en orthographe, je l’avoue,
mais c’est bien plus que ça.
Et aujourd’hui, mon but,
c’est de vous faire comprendre
ce que ça implique sur le quotidien.
Donc, on l’a déjà vu,
le premier impact,
c’est au niveau de l’écriture :
avec toutes ces règles orthographiques
qui ne rentrent pas,
ces lettres qui se mélangent
et qui se confondent,
ces sons qui parfois
ne se distinguent même pas.
Je me souviens
d’une de mes profs d’anglais
qui est venue me voir à la fin,
après avoir rendu un contrôle
de vocabulaire à mes camarades.
Elle est venue me voir et m’a dit :
« Ah, Audrey, je suis vraiment embêtée.
Je vois que tu as travaillé parce que
les lettres, dans le mot de vocabulaire,
tu les as toutes,
mais pas dans le bon ordre.
Du coup, forcément, je ne peux pas
te mettre une bonne note,
mais c’est bien,
tu progresses, continue. »
Et ça a été mon quotidien au lycée
et au collège pour tout ce qui est dictée,
orthographe, les points malus
parce qu’on est trop nul en orthographe,
c’était mon quotidien.
Mais qui dit écriture dit aussi lecture.
Vous l’aurez deviné, je lis beaucoup
moins vite que la plupart des gens.
Mais devinerez-vous à quel point
je lis plus lentement ?
Si je compare mon temps de lecture
sur une minute avec d’autres personnes,
je vois que je suis presque
deux fois plus lente
qu’une personne n’ayant pas de trouble.
Pire, je lis même moins vite
qu’une personne dont la langue natale
n’est pas le français.
Pire encore, je lis même moins vite
qu'une enfant de huit ans.
C'est un peu la honte, je l'avoue.
Mais bon, ce n’est pas si grave.
L’autre chose qui est moins connue,
c’est que ces sons qui se mélangent,
à l’écrit et à la lecture,
se mélangent aussi dans l’oreille.
On a vu qu’au niveau de l’expression,
cela impacte -
merci les chaussettes -
mais aussi au niveau de la compréhension.
Parfois, quand il y a beaucoup de bruit
ou quand je suis fatiguée,
il est très difficile pour moi
de suivre une conversation,
de comprendre ce qui est dit.
Et ça, c'est dans ma propre langue.
Je me sens parfois étrangère
dans ma propre langue.
Alors imaginez en anglais,
c’est très, très compliqué.
La dernière chose que j’aimerais
vous partager sur ces impacts,
c’est ma relation avec les chiffres.
Il est très difficile pour moi
de me représenter
et d’interpréter les chiffres.
Par exemple, je ne connais absolument
pas mon code de carte bleue.
Ça ne va pas m’empêcher de le taper
pour faire des achats,
parce que finalement, ce que j’ai retenu,
c’est le mouvement
que je fais sur le terminal.
Et puis c’est vrai que maintenant,
avec le paiement sans contact,
c’est quand même vachement plus facile.
Par contre, quand un de mes collègues
va me dire :
« Mais tiens, toi, t’as fait une
université en maths, t'es une matheuse.
Fais-nous ce calcul mental
super simple, super facile.
Toi, ça va prendre deux secondes. »
Non, ça ne va pas
me prendre deux secondes.
Il va falloir que je sorte le papier,
le crayon pour le faire.
Et encore, même là, ça sera compliqué.
Finalement pour toutes ces choses
qui peuvent pour vous paraître si simples,
pour moi, ça va demander beaucoup plus
d'efforts, beaucoup plus d'énergie.
Forcément, ça va impliquer
une surcharge de fatigue.
Cette fatigue va en plus fragiliser
ma capacité de mémorisation
qui est déjà impactée par mes troubles.
C’est pour toutes ces raisons
que les troubles dys
sont reconnus comme un handicap,
invisible, certes,
mais un handicap bien réel.
En tant qu’étudiant, les personnes
ayant des troubles dys
ont le droit à des tiers temps
et à des aménagements.
En tant qu’adulte, on a le droit
au statut de travailleur handicapé,
ce qui permet d’avoir
un aménagement du poste de travail.
Pourtant être dys,
ce n’est pas être stupide
ou feignant,
comme on nous l’a souvent répété
encore et encore pendant des années,
et ce jusqu’à il n’y a pas si longtemps.
Si nous prenons par exemple Einstein,
Louis Pasteur, Jules Verne,
Agatha Christie.
Quatre grands noms
qui ont marqué notre histoire,
tant sur le plan scientifique
que sur le plan littéraire.
Quatre dyslexiques.
Alors je ne prétends pas avoir
l’intelligence de Louis Pasteur
ou la prose d’Agatha Christie,
même si j’avoue que j’aimerais bien.
Mais je pense qu’à mon niveau,
à mon échelle, j’ai réussi une prouesse
que moi-même et mes parents
n’imaginions pas possible à l’époque.
Cette prouesse, ça a été
de faire de longues études,
une licence en mathématiques,
puis un master et un doctorat
en cryptographie.
Pour réaliser ce doctorat, j'ai dû lire
énormément d'articles en anglais.
J'ai même dû rédiger un manuscrit
de plus de 100 pages.
Vous imaginez plus de 100 pages ?
Un truc de dingue pour moi.
Ça a été compliqué, ça a été difficile,
mais j’y suis arrivée
grâce à des stratégies, des méthodes
et des compétences que j’ai acquises
tout au long de mon parcours.
Et aujourd’hui, j’aimerais
vous en partager certains.
La première chose que j’ai retenue
pendant mon parcours,
ça a été que l’entraînement
et la répétition sont la clé du succès.
Bien évidemment, quand on est jeune,
qu’on nous demande de faire un exercice
pour lequel on n’est pas doué,
qu’en plus on nous gronde
parce qu’on n’y arrive pas
et qu’enfin les camarades se moquent
parce qu’on n’y arrive toujours pas,
on n’a pas envie de s’entraîner.
C'est quelque chose de rédhibitoire.
C'est ce qui s'est passé pour moi
quand j'ai dû apprendre à lire.
Ce que mes parents ont fait,
c’est qu’ils ne m’ont pas laissé le choix.
Je devais, le soir, après l’école,
faire des séances de lecture à voix haute.
Mais là où ils ont été malins,
c’est qu’ils ont fait en sorte
de rendre ces séances agréables.
C’était un endroit où j’étais protégée.
J’avais le droit de me tromper,
j’avais le droit de lire lentement.
C'était bienveillant et finalement,
c'était un moment privilégié avec eux.
Je me souviens encore de ce livre
qui parlait de trois petits chats
qui faisaient des bêtises et c’est là
que j’ai appris à lire mieux.
J'ai appris que la lecture
pouvait être un plaisir.
Et depuis, je ne me suis jamais arrêtée.
Ces entraînements de lecture
peuvent prendre d’autres formes.
Ça peut être, par exemple,
de demander à votre enfant
de lire la recette de cuisine
que vous êtes en train de faire.
Il aura ainsi l'impression de participer
et d'avoir un moment privilégié avec vous.
Ce qui est valable pour la lecture
l'est aussi pour l'écriture.
Pour ces entraînements,
il existe des plateformes en ligne
qui permettent de faire des exercices
orthographiques et de grammaire.
J’en fais moi-même
encore très régulièrement
pour avoir un niveau
d’orthographe correct.
Ces exercices peuvent aussi être
simplifiés grâce à des supports.
Ça peut être, par exemple,
de changer la police d’écriture.
Pour ma part, je préfère
des polices qui sont rondes,
avec des caractères
et des lignes espacées.
D'ailleurs, il existe une police
spécifiquement créée pour les dyslexiques
qui ont chaque caractère différent.
Pour le support, pour ma part,
je préfère avoir des feuilles sans lignes
et si en plus elles pouvaient être
jaune pâle, alors là c’est le luxe.
La cerise sur le gâteau !
Ces préférences me sont propres,
elles ne vont pas forcément correspondre
à tous les dyslexiques.
Je sais par exemple qu’un de mes amis
qui a les mêmes troubles que moi
va préférer une feuille bleu pâle.
Alors surtout, n’hésitez pas à essayer,
à expérimenter de nouvelles choses,
de nouvelles polices,
de nouvelles couleurs,
de nouveaux supports pour trouver
ce qui vous convient le mieux.
Malheureusement, ces adaptations
ne sont pas toujours suffisantes.
C’est ce que j’ai remarqué
lorsque j’ai dû passer mon bac,
où je voyais tous mes camarades
faire des petites fiches de révision
toutes compactes, toute mini,
avec plein d’écritures.
J’ai essayé d’en faire,
ça ne fonctionnait pas pour moi.
Alors j’ai demandé conseil
à l’orthophoniste
qui me suivait à l’époque
et elle m’a dit : « Non Audrey,
franchement, laisse tomber,
les fiches, ce n’est pas pour toi.
Toi, ce que tu peux faire, par contre,
ce sont des panneaux. »
Alors j'ai fait des panneaux.
J'ai utilisé le même support feuilles
jaunes et puis j'ai aéré le contenu.
J’ai mis des dessins, de la couleur,
j’ai donné du sens à des informations
qui n’en avaient pas.
Et ce panneau, je l’ai accroché
sur le mur de ma chambre
parce que c’est un endroit
où j’allais souvent,
car la répétition est la clé.
Et c’est comme ça
que j’ai passé mes examens.
Vous n’imaginez même pas la tête
de ma chambre à chaque partiel,
on ne voyait même plus les murs.
Mais ces supports
ne sont pas toujours suffisants.
Il est nécessaire d'apprendre
à travailler différemment.
Parce qu’il est totalement
contre-productif pour moi
de travailler deux ou trois heures
d’affilée sans faire de pauses.
Au bout d'un moment, plus rien ne rentre.
Alors ce que j’ai mis en place,
ce sont des cycles de travail.
Je vais travailler par exemple une heure
et faire dix minutes de pause.
Si je sais que je suis fatiguée,
si je le ressens,
je vais travailler 50 minutes
et je vais faire dix minutes de pause.
Pendant ce temps de travail,
je vais être ultra-efficace,
je vais vraiment me concentrer à ça.
Et pendant ce temps de repos, je vais
pouvoir souffler sans culpabiliser,
faire une vraie pause.
Nous avons vu comment réviser,
comment passer des partiels.
Mais que se passe-t-il
quand on est devant sa feuille
et qu’il faut le passer ce partiel ?
Mais là, je n’aurais qu’un conseil,
et ça, je suis sûre
que vous l’avez déjà entendu
par au moins un de vos profs.
On lit tout l’énoncé en entier
dès le début
et on commence toujours
par ce qu’on sait faire.
On garantit comme ça un maximum de points
qui sont d’ailleurs faciles
pour nous à avoir.
Le reste, on le fait dans le temps
qu’il nous reste.
Bien évidemment, ceci ne fonctionne
pas pour les présentations
comme celle d’aujourd’hui.
On ne peut pas commencer par la fin,
revenir en arrière, puis repartir
au début, sauter une partie.
On est obligé de suivre un fil rouge,
une histoire
pour ne pas perdre tout le monde.
Alors ce que vont faire
certaines personnes,
c’est d’écrire un texte
et ils vont l’apprendre par cœur.
Et le jour J, ils vont vous le réciter
à la virgule près.
Impossible pour moi, ça me demanderait
trop d’efforts, trop d’énergie,
trop de temps.
Et le jour J, je suis presque sûre
d'oublier quelque chose.
Et finalement, qu’est-ce que je fais
à cause de cet oubli ?
Ce que je vais faire, plutôt,
c’est de faire un squelette
avec les points clés
de ce qui doit absolument être dit.
L'essentiel.
Une fois que ce squelette
est stable et établi,
je vais répéter encore et encore
car la répétition est la clé.
Mais je vais répéter
dans des conditions différentes.
Je vais aller en pleine nature,
ou dans ma voiture, ou dans mon salon,
je vais mettre de la musique à fond,
je vais être dans le silence total.
Je vais répéter très, très, vite
et très, très, très fort,
ou alors très doucement
et même en parlant tout bas.
L’important, pour ces répétitions,
c’est de réussir à se déconcentrer,
mais surtout à se recentrer
pour revenir sur l’histoire
qu’on doit raconter.
C'est comme ça que j'ai préparé
cette présentation.
Mais plus que des techniques
et des stratégies,
ce que j’ai dû développer,
ce sont des compétences, des qualités.
La première chose que j’ai dû apprendre
à faire, c’est à m’adapter,
ne serait-ce que pour aller
chercher du pain.
Plus, j’ai aussi appris à être
bienveillante et patiente.
Déjà envers les autres,
mais surtout envers moi-même.
Je ne vais pas me flageller
parce que j’ai raté une fois.
Au contraire, j’ai raté ?
Ce n’est pas grave, je recommence.
Ça prendra le temps qu'il faudra,
mais j'y arriverai.
Bienveillance et patience.
Ensuite, j'ai osé me dépasser.
J’ai osé surmonter le regard des autres
pour ne plus avoir peur de parler
devant les autres et avec les autres.
Grâce à ça, j'ai osé poser des questions.
J'ai osé demander de l'aide
quand j'en avais besoin.
J’ai osé me lancer
plein de nouveaux défis.
J’ai aussi osé me donner
les moyens de réussir ces défis.
Et aujourd’hui, j’ai osé
me présenter devant vous
pour faire cette présentation
pour le TEDx.
Et je vous remercie de votre attention.
(Applaudissements)